Christmas or variations thereof are celebrated the world over.
Originally a celebration of the birth of Jesus for Christian religion,...
...Christmas has achieved an immense popularity with non-Christians as well.
Though not a formally recognized holiday,...
...many Eastern countries like China and Japan have adopted some of the festivities...
...that go along with a secular Christmas.
Today, Christmas as we know it is celebrated...
...with the decorating of a tree, room, house and or yard with lights, ornaments...
...and plants such as holly and mistletoe.
A feast with family and friends usually accompanies one or both of Christmas Eve or day.
And of course, the giving, receiving and opening of gifts with loved ones.
Regardless of religious persuasion, Christmas is a jolly holiday...
...enjoyed by many throughout the globe.